[Music]
hello i'm brian kerris technical
director of graphics here at epic games
hi i'm george of the special project
a few years ago we got together as a
team and brainstormed where we thought
we could push
forward the state of the art and
real-time graphics there were two key
areas that stood out
the first dynamic global illumination
beautiful bounce lighting
instantaneously i don't have to be
constrained to do a game where the world
has to be static
and i may be able to interact a lot
faster and we call this new system
lumen we're about to show you what it is
capable of
but first there was another area that we
thought we could push forward
truly virtualized geometry the artist
wouldn't have to be concerned over poly
counts
draw calls or memory you could directly
use
film quality assets and bring them
straight into the engine and that's a
big deal for artists
i just want to be able to import my
zbrush model my photogrammetry scan
my cad data without wasting any time
optimizing
creating leds or even lowering the
quality to make it hit frame rate
in the end that's what it's all about
art that just works
and we call this new technology nanite
here is the future of
unreal engine running live on a
playstation 5.
awesome let's take a look at it
[Music]
this has to be
[Applause]
before we continue let's stop a moment
and take a look at some of the key
features of this demo
much of what you see was built with
qixel mega scan assets
but instead of using the game versions
we used the cinematic versions which
would typically only be used in film
there are around a million triangles
each and thanks to virtual texturing
they all use 8k textures as well nanite
can render an insane number of triangles
very quickly
there are over a billion triangles of
source geometry in each frame
that nanite crunches down losslessly to
around 20 million drawn triangles
what does that many triangles look like
this isn't noise
these are the triangles each a different
color most are so small that they look
like noise
nanite achieves detail down to the pixel
which means triangles are often the size
of pixels
this amount of geometric detail requires
shadows to be pixel accurate as well
and nanite can do that too speaking of
lighting
all of the lighting in this demo is
completely dynamic with the power of
lumen that even includes multi-bounce
global illumination
no light maps no baking here without gi
all of that beautiful lighting is gone
with lumen enabled we can move the light
and the bounce changes instantly
okay let's keep going
we've made some great additions to our
audio system as well
convolution reverb allows us to measure
reverberation characteristics of real
spaces
like actual caves that we sampled and
reproduce them in virtual spaces
sound field rendering allows us to
record and playback spatialized audio
all of this adds up to a more immersive
experience
this swarm of bats was created with a
niagara effect system
particles in niagara can now talk to one
another and understand their environment
like never before
we've also added a ton of new
functionality to run fluid simulations
like you see in the water below
[Music]
[Applause]
the demo runs on our chaos physics
system here we are using it to
accurately simulate the rigid bodies
of the falling rocks and the cloth of
her scarf
now that the environment is so complex
we've needed to greatly improve our
animation systems to adapt
we've added predictive foot placement
and motion warping which dynamically
modifies ik and body position
to look more natural for the character
to more realistically interact with the
environment
we've added the ability to trigger
seamless contextual animation events
like her hand on the door promising
[Music]
dynamic gi is amazing not just for
speeding up iteration
but also for its impact on gameplay
any light source can move while still
having beautiful bounce lighting
dynamic illumination means specular as
well which you can see on all the metal
surfaces
you can even see the niagara-powered
bugs reacting to the light
lumen not only reacts to moving light
sources but also changes in geometry
remember we mentioned high poly assets
this statue was imported directly from
zbrush
and is more than 33 million triangles no
baking of normal maps
no authored lods
and we can do more than a single statue
there are nearly
500 of that exact statue at the same
detail level placed in this room
for a total of over 16 billion triangles
from statues alone
over this entire demo there are hundreds
of billions of triangles
[Music]
so with nanite you have limitless
geometry and with lumen
you have fully dynamic lighting and
global illumination
all running on a playstation 5.
[Music]
there's not much time left this doesn't
need to be constrained
to small rooms it can stretch all the
way to the horizon
the portal is open
don't fail me now
ugh
wow
it's time to see what's next
[Music]
you